Hello, this is Dr.
Eugene Petko, and
today we'll talk
about hemostasis.
The session objectives are,
one, to evaluate the
normal anti-clotting
mechanism, and to
evaluate various stages
of hemostasis, namely,
vasoconstriction,
primary hemostasis,
secondary hemostasis,
clot retraction, and
repair and fibrinolysis.
By definition, hemostasis
is the process by which
blood clots form at the
sites of vascular injury. It
is essential for life and
is abnormal in hemorrhagic
disorders and thrombotic
disorders. Hemorrhagic
disorders are characterized
by excessive bleeding and
the hemostatic mechanisms
are either blunted or
insufficient to prevent the
blood loss. By contrast,
the thrombotic disorders
are characterized by
blood clots formation
with intact blood vessels.
Let's talk about
endothelium in hemostasis.
Normal endothelium
is antithrombotic.
This is achieved by
its antiplatelet,
anticoagulant, and fibrinolytic
action. The antiplatelet
action is dependent
by the synthesis
of prostaglandin I2,
nitric oxide, and adenosine
disphosphatase by the
endothelial cells.
These will act in concert
and will inhibit platelet
adhesion and aggregation.
The anticoagulant action
is achieved by synthesis
of heparin-like molecules,
tissue factor pathway
inhibitor, and thrombomodulin.
The heparin-like molecules
will bind antithrombin
tree, which in turn will
inactivate thrombin and
factors 9a and 10a. The
tissue factor pathway
inhibitor inactivates, as
you can see in this drawing,
tissue factor 7A complexes,
while thrombomodulin
will bind thrombin and
will convert it from
a procoagulant to an
anticoagulant state via
activation of protein C,
inhibiting clothing as
well as factor 5a and 8a.
In addition,
the endothelium will
also make protein
S which is a cofactor
for protein C.
The fibrinolytic action
is achieved via synthesis
of tissue plasminogen
activator a protease which
cleaves plasminogen to
plasmin. The plasmin,
in turn, would cleave
fibrin to degrade thrombi.
An endothelial trauma or
inflammation would lead
to protrombosis,
allowing the platelets to
contact the underlying
extracellular matrix.
Adhesion will occur via
the von Willebrand factor
which is a normal product
of endothelial cells.
A damaged or inflamed
endothelium will also make
tissue factor in response
to cytokines and this is
a major activator of
extrinsic clothing cascade.
Also a damaged or inflamed
endothelial will manufacture
inhibitors of plasminogen
activator inhibitor which
will limit fibrinolysis
and will favor thrombosis.
So the first stage
of hemostasis is
represented by arterial
vasoconstriction. So,
the endothelial cells
release endothelin.
Now,
the endothelin will promote
vasoconstriction. However,
the smooth muscle cells
might be injured as well,
and they will enhance the
vasoconstriction via a
direct myogenic effect.
In addition, the BK
nociceptors inducing pain
are activated. As a result,
there will also be a
reflex visoconstriction.
subsequent to vasoconstriction
platelets adhesion
takes place at this
point we have a damaged
endothelium as seen in this
drawing with exposure of
the subendothelial matrix
and collagen fibrils
and in parallel the
synthesis of von Willebrand
factor by the endothelial
cells continues. The adhesion
is mediated mostly by
this von Willebrand
factor, which acts as a
bridge between platelet
surface receptor, glycoprotein
1b, and the collagen.
Also, binding of platelets
to glycoprotein 1b to
von Willebrand factor will
promote release of ADP,
thromboxane A2, and
serotonin. All these
factors are very important
in blood clotting
and platelet adhesion
and aggregation.
Following adhesion platelets
will change their shape
from a smooth round oval
structure they will become
spiky as seen in this nice
scanning electron microscopy
picture. You see on their
surface, they present with
elongations. In fact,
these elongations represent
conformational changes in cell
structural glycoprotein 2b3a,
which will increase their
affinity for fibrinogen.
The changing shape
is associated with
translocation of negatively
charged phospholipids,
particularly phosphatidylserine
to the platelet surface.
Subsequently, these
phospholipids will bind
calcium and will serve
as a nucleation site
for assembly of coagulation
factor complexes.
The changing in
shape is associated
with secretion of
granules. This depends
on ADP, thrombin
and thromboxane A2.
what's happening is that
the platelet receptors will
interact with this agonist
and will start intracellular
protein phosphorylation
cascade ultimately leading
to degranulation and we
have two different type of
granules the alpha granule
containing the p-selectin
fibrinogen factor 5 von
Willebrand factor fibronectin
platelet factor 4 platelet
derived growth factor
and transforming growth
factor B and dense granules
ADP, ATP, serotonin,
epinephrine and calcium.
Calcium is very important
for the clothing cascade
while ADP is an activator
of aggregation and
serotonin and epinephrine
are vasoconstrictors.
As the ultimate goal of primary
hemostasis formation
of primary prague,
the ADP will trigger
conformational change
in platelets, increasing
the expression on
their surface of
glycoprotein 2b3a receptors.
Subsequently, fibrinogen
will be able to
bind these receptors
and link platelets,
promoting a formation
of the primary plaque.
In terms of aggregation, which
is described at this point,
this is modulated by
Tromboxyn A2, a potent
vasoconstrictor
released by platelets,
which will amplify
aggregation and will lead
to formation of primary
hemostatic plaque.
Please note that aspirin
will inhibit platelet
aggregation by inhibiting
cyclooxygenase platelet
enzyme needed for
thromboxane A2 synthesis.
Concurrent activation of
clothin cascade stabilizes a
platelet plaque because
thrombin On one side binds to
a platelet receptor along
with ADP and thromboxene A2,
causing further aggregation,
followed by platelet
contraction, and also thrombin
will convert fibrinogen
to fibrin, cementing
platelets in place. As
you can see in this drawing,
activation and secretion
are extremely important
for aggregation and
formation of the primary
plug at the site of injury.
In summary, primary
hemostasis has several stages.
The first is represented
by platelet adhesion,
followed by platelet
activation. In fact, platelet
activation is composed
of one stage in which
the platelets change
their shape and one stage
in which they release
their granule content.
Then we have platelet
recruitment and ultimately
formation of the primary
hemostatic plaque.
It is obvious that the
platelets have a very
important role in a
hemostatic process, and
their function is
evaluated by bleeding time.
This is a clinical
laboratory test in which a
standardized incision is
performed, and then the
time to cessation of
bleeding is measured. The
historical indications
for bleeding time were in
the preoperative assessment
of patients with von
Willebrand disease, as
well as those taking
aspirin or non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs.
Secondary hemostasis, in
fact, it's represented by
the coagulation cascade.
At this stage, there is
significant deposition and
polymerization of fibrin,
which consolidates the
initial platelet plug.
Well, clothing can
be studied in the
laboratory or in vivo.
And in laboratory,
fiber-encloth formation
results through
an intrinsic or an
extrinsic pathway. The
intrinsic pathway
requires the presence of
negatively charged
surface glass beads.
The factor 12 will
interact with these
negatively charges and
will activate itself.
And subsequently, this
will activate factor
11 and 9. Factor 9,
along with factor 8,
will activate factor 10.
Then this activated
factor 10 will modulate
transformation of proton
bin into thrombin, which
ultimately transforms
fibrinogen into a fibrin cloth.
The extrinsic pathway
requires the addition
of tissue factor, which
activates factor 7.
which will also lead
to activation of factor
X. So factor X is the
common point where
the intrinsic and
extrinsic pathway converge.
In vivo, the vascular
damage results in exposure
of the tissue factor,
which activates factor VII.
Factor VII and tissue
factor will will
modulate activation
of factor 9, and
this can be activated
by factor 11.
And an activated factor
9 along with an activated
factor 8 will transform an
inactive factor 10 into an
active factor 10a. And
subsequently, the steps to fibrin
cloth formation are similar
with these steps already
described in the case of
clothing in the laboratory.
So the intrinsic
pathway is activated
by damage inside
the vasculature.
Basically, the platelets
are exposed to damaged
endothelium and subendothelial
extracellular matrix and
collagen. It is slower
than the extrinsic pathway,
and it generates a more
robust coagulation response.
It is measured by
partial thromboplastin
time. Normally this
is 25 to 40 seconds.
The clothing is initiated
by adding negatively
charged particles, which
activate factor 13,
phospholipids and
calcium. then the time to
fibrin cloth is
recorded. It is used in
monitoring heparin therapy
and gives an indication
to factors 12, 11,
9, 8, 10, 2, and 1.
The extrinsic pathway,
it is activated by trauma
that causes blood to
leave vasculature. It is
quicker than the intrinsic
pathway and it is
measured by protrombin
time. Normally this is 11
to 15 seconds and in
this case tissue factor
and phospholipids are
added to citrated plasma.
Then time to fibrin cloth
is recorded. It is used
in in monitoring warfarin
therapy and gives
indications relating to
factors 7, 10, 2, and 1.
This is a table with
all the clofine factors,
you have all their full
name, their function,
as well as their
plasma characteristics.
Well, since we have already
mentioned thrombin several
times, it is very important
to highlight its roles.
Thrombin promotes splattered
aggregation and activation.
It will promote thromboxin
A2 synthesis. It will
convert fibrinogen into
cross-linked fibrin. It will
stimulate endothelial
cell, which in turn will
manufacture adhesion
molecules and growth factors.
such as PDGF.
Also it has anticoagulant
effects on normal endothelium.
This is so that
clotting does not
extend beyond the
site of injury.
Anticoagulation.
Anticoagulation occurs during
primary and secondary
hemostasis and regulates
clot formation. It
prevents clots from growing
too large. If the clots
grow too large, they
will block the blood flow
and will form emboli.
Regulation starts with
thrombin but there are
other factors that have
anticoagulation action.
For example protein C and S
bind thrombomodulin thrombin
complex and cleaves and
inactivates factor 5 and
8 antithrombin 3 binds
thrombin and factor 10 and
significantly inactivates both,
plus, in addition, it will
bind with lower affinity
factors 7, 9, 11, and 12.
Other factors prevent
platelets adhering
during primary
hemostasis, for example,
nitric oxide and prostaglandin
I2-prostacycline,
which will decrease
thromboxane A2.
Several words about
cloth stabilization
and retraction. First of all,
this is a nice scanning
electron microscopy picture.
Please note the fine threads
of fibrin. Anyway, once
this structure is formed
and becomes a stable cloth,
the platelets
contract within this
environment and
the cloth shrinks.
The fibrin mesh becomes
more compact and
overall the edges of
the damaged vessels are
brought together.
The fluid is squeezed
from the cloth and this
makes it more solid.
The fluid which is
squeezed is serum,
which in fact is plasma
minus fibrinogen and clotting
factors, which have been
removed during clothing.
Fibrinolysis or
fibrinolytic cascade.
Activation of
coagulation cascade also
activates activates
fibrinolitic cascade to
moderate the size of
the clot being formed.
On this diagram,
please note the activated
factor 12, which acts upon
plasma calicrine and
transforms it into calicrine.
Calicrine acts in
concert with tissue
plasminogen activator
and urokinase,
transforming
plasminogen into active
plasmin, which
subsequently acts upon the
fibrin meshwork and
transforms it into soluble
fibrinopeptides,
dissolving the cloth.
Synthetic streptokinase
and neurokinase facilitate
transformation of
plasminogen into plasmin.
However, the action of
plasmin can be inhibited
by tranexamic acid and
alpha 2 antiplasmin.
In conclusion, plasmin
is generated by enzymatic
catabolism of the precursor
plasminogen, either by a factor
12-dependent pathway or
plasminogen activators. The
most important plasminogen
activator is TPA. This
is manufactured by the
endothelial cells and is most
active when bound to fibrin.
It is a very important
therapeutic agent because it's
fibrinolytic activity it's
mostly confined to the
sites of recent thrombosis.
In summary, hemostasis consists
of several phases,
vascular phase,
primary hemostasis or
platelet phase which
results in formation of
the primary platelet plug,
secondary hemostasis
or coagulation phase
which results in
formation of a stable
secondary platelet plug, and
fibrinolytic phase in which
there is dissolution
of the platelet plug
and re-establishment
of the blood flow.